okay so you mentioned
asr can you speak to what is
asr automatic speech recognition how
much
like what is the gap between perfect
human performance
and uh perfect or pretty damn good asr
yeah so is our automatic speech
recognition it's a
class of machine learning problem right
to take you know speech like
we were talking and transform it into a
sequence of words essentially
audio of people talking audio audio to
words
and you know there's a variety of
different approaches and techniques
which we could talk about later if you
want
so you know we think we have pretty much
the world's best asr for this kind of
um speech right so there's there's
different kinds of domains right for asr
like one domain might be
voice assistance right so siri um
very different than what we're doing
right because siri there's fairly
limited vocabulary
you know you know you might ask siri to
play a song or you know order pizza or
whatever
um and it's very good at doing that very
different from when we start talking in
a very unstructured way
and siri will also generally like adapt
to your voice and stuff like this
so for this kind of audio we think we
have the best and
our accuracy right now
i think it's maybe 14 were there read on
on uh
our test test suite that we generally
used to measure the word error rate is
like one way to measure
uh accuracy for asr right so what's
fourteen percent
fourteen percent means across this test
suite
of a variety of different audios um
it would be um it would get
in some way 14 of the words wrong
uh 14 of the words wrong yeah so
the way you kind of calculate it is you
might add up
insertions deletions and substitutions
right so
insertions is like extra words deletions
are words that
we said but um weren't in the transcript
right substitutions says
you said apple but i said but the sr i
thought it was able something like this
um human accuracy most people think
realistically it's like three percent
two percent
word error rate would be like the max
achievable
so there's still quite a gap right would
you say that
so youtube when i upload videos often
generates automatic captions
are you sort of from a company
perspective from a
tech perspective are you trying to beat
youtube
google it's a hell of a so google i mean
i don't know how seriously they take
this task but i imagine it's quite
serious
and they you know google is probably
up there in terms of their teams on um
on asr or just nlp natural language
processing different technologies
so do you think you can be google on
this kind of stuff yeah we think so
um google just woke up on my phone this
is hilarious okay now google is
listening
sending it back to headquarters for
these rough people
but that's the goal yeah i mean we
measure ourselves against like google
amazon
microsoft you know some of the some
smaller competitors
um and we use like our internal tests
we try to compose it of a pretty
representative set of audios maybe it's
some podcasts some videos some intro
some interviews some lectures things
like that right
and we beat them in our own testing
and uh actually rev offers automated
like you can actually just do the
automated uh captioning
so like i guess it's like way cheaper
whatever it is
whatever the rates are yeah yeah so by
the way it used to be a dollar per
minute
for captioning and transcription i think
it's like a dollar
fifteen or something like that
twenty-five dollar twenty-five
1.25 now yeah it's pr it's pretty cool
that was the other thing that was
surprising to me it was actually
like the cheapest thing you could one of
i mean i i don't remember it being
cheaper you could on upwork get cheaper
but it was clear to me that this that's
going to be really shitty
yeah it's like you're also competing on
price i think there were services
that you can get like similar to rev
kind of
um feel to it but it wasn't as automated
like the drag and drop the entirety of
the interface it's like the thing we're
talking about
i'm such a huge fan of like frictionless
like uh
amazon's single uh
buy button whatever yeah yeah that one
click
the one click that's genius right there
like that is so
important for services yeah that's
simplicity
and i mean rev is is uh almost there
i mean there's like some i'm trying to
think
so i i think i've uh
i stopped using uh this pipeline but rev
offers it and that i like it but it was
causing me some
issues uh on my side which is um
you can connect it to like dropbox and
it generates the files and dropbox
so like it it it closes the loop to
where i don't have to go to rev at all
and i can download it uh um sorry i
don't have to go
to rev at all and to download the files
it could just like
automatically copy them all right you
put in your dropbox and you know
a day later or maybe a few hours later
yeah eventually
it just yeah yeah i was trying to do it
programmatically too
is there an api interface you can i was
trying to
through like through python to download
stuff automatically
but then i realized this is the
programmer in me like
dude you don't need to automate
everything like in life just like
flawlessly because i wasn't doing enough
captions to
justify to myself the time investment
into automating everything perfectly
yeah i would say if you're doing so many
interviews that your biggest
roadblock is uh clicking on the rough
download button
now now you're talking about elon musk
levels of business
but for sure we have like a variety of
ways to make it easy you know there's
the integration you mentioned i think
it's through a company called sapir
which
kind of can connect um dropbox to raven
uh vice versa we have an api if you want
to really like customize it you know
if you want to create the lux friedman
you know
cms or or whatever for this whole thing
okay cool
so can you speak to the the
asr a little bit more like what is it uh
what does it take like approach wise
machine learning wise how hard is this
problem
how do you get to the three percent
error rate like what's your vision of
all of this
yeah well the three percent rate of air
rate is definitely
that's that's the grand vision um
we'll see what it takes to get there um
but we believe you know in in asr
the biggest thing is the data right like
that's true of like a lot of machine
learning problems today right
the more data you have and high quality
the data the better label the data
um yeah that doesn't get good results
and
we at rev have kind of like the best
data like we have like you're literally
your literal model is annotating the
data our business model is
being paid to annotate the data
so it's kind of like a pretty magical
flywheel yeah
and so we've kind of like ridden this
flywheel to to this point
um and we think we're still
kind of in the early stages of figuring
out all the parts of the flywheel to use
you know because
we have the final transcripts and we
have the
the audios and we train on that but
we in principle also have all the edits
that the reverse make
right um oh that's interesting how can
you use that as they do
we have that's that's something for us
to figure out in the future but you know
we feel like we're only in the early
stages right so the data but the data is
there
that'd be interesting like almost like a
recurrent neural net for fixing
for fixing transcripts i i always
remember
we did uh segmentation annotation for uh
for driving data so
segmenting the scene like visual data
and you could
you can get all so it was drawing people
drawing polygons
around different objects and so on and
it feels like
it always felt like there was a lot of
information
in the clicking the sequence of clicking
that people do the kind of fixing of the
pod guns that they do
now there's a few papers written about
how to
draw polygons like with uh recurrent
neural nets
to try to learn from the human clicking
but it was just like experimental
you know it was one of those like cvpr
type papers that people do like a really
tiny data set it didn't feel like people
really tried to do it seriously yeah i
wonder
i wonder if there's information in the
fixing that's
high that that provides deeper
set of signal than just like the raw
uh data the intuition is for sure there
must be right it must be
in in in all kinds of signals and how
long it took to you know make that edit
and stuff like that
uh you know it's gonna be like up to us
that's why like
the next couple years is like super
exciting for us right so that's what
like the focus is now is
you mentioned rev.a.i that's where you
want to yeah so wrap the ai is kind of
um
our way of bringing this asr to
you know the rest of the world right so
when we started um
we were human only and you know then we
kind of created this
uh temi service i think you might have
used it which was kind of asr for the
consumer right so if you don't want to
pay a dollar 25
but you want to paid now it's 25 cents a
minute i think and
you gather um the transcript the machine
generated transcript
you get an editor and you can kind of
fix it up yourself right
then we started using dsr for our own
human transcriptionists
and then the kind of ai is the final
step of the journey which is you know we
have this amazing
engine what can people build with it
right what kind of
new applications could be enabled
um if you have speed track that's that
accurate
you